welcome everybody to a an incredibly
special Thanksgiving special I want to
say even of the h3 podcast live every
Friday or Tuesday at twitch.tv 4/3 who
ruptured today our episode is sponsored
by video blocks and me undies more on
that later but I want to tell you about
our lust rias guests they've pretty much
been intertwined with our own fates and
Hilo of course art so I was like ok
they've been intertwined with our fate
on YouTube since the beginning of time
from pranks in the hood you know to
spider-man and Elsa to their later work
Sunset Park head on over to Brad Berry
Farms and pick yourself a fresh one
because today our guests are mo anything
Bradbury and a and I'll tell you what
these guys they came right and you'll
see what I see in a moment and I and and
you know the reason for my weird aside
there was that I was so excited to
welcome back finally ela Klein thank you
or she known in some circles hula
kleiner what a hula kleiner how's it to
be back it's great it's really really
great
I was [ __ ] yeah I think out here with
you dude who those solo streams are not
easy oh my god it's like you got nothing
to play off up you got no one to talk to
I'm out here I'm dying dance starts
talking to me over the mic I'm like I
must be palming it wasn't easy in Israel
- I gotta tell everyone who's living in
California you guys live in the utopian
world it's true um no humidity no
mosquitoes no people yelling at you
people just yell you in Israel doesn't
matter what you're doing this is utopia
Dan I can hear you out the speaker so
without further ado I also just want to
say before I bring in the boys that on
Tuesday October is the slamming month we
have a ton of great guests this month
lined up Tuesday we have Tai Lopez
coming up so
like last time with the Bradbury's we
said post your questions for them and
I'd like to have that be an ongoing
thing so head on over to the subreddit
reddit.com slash are slash our issues
reductions and there's a thread there
stick it to the top questions for ty
Lopez well listen I think we've
introduced them enough for for pizza
sake my whole life has led up into this
moment I feel like so damn let's let's
bring them in do it that is your seat by
the way you didn't this is a podcast no
can you take care of your brother Spidey
come on Doc this one is Spidey such a
troublemaker you suppose clean up this
damn city guys I'm honored to have you
guys here with us oh yeah I mean duh so
we we uh basically yeah you got to hold
the mic like right up to to your mouth
you got to kiss that yeah yeah you got
to kiss that thing Ethan are you gonna
talk are you gonna join us in
conversation boys okay good good I love
it and use your brother right
setting up yeah nice that's gently and
apparently unexpected twist so thanks
for coming guys yeah thank you for
having us what are you guys doing in LA
by the way just filming a couple things
oh yeah yeah YouTube stuff yeah can I
can I get a what do you guys working on
or is it top secret stuff it'll be all
right we I like that yeah there prank um
I don't want to call it a prank it's
like a whole bunch of things Synnex is
this social more of a social experiment
and everything put together whoa all
right I can't wait to see it
well I listen you guys out mean me today
you showed up in the goddamn spider-man
and this is how I wear my clothes at
home dude you fill that thing and nicely
it's really nice because I have one and
doesn't fit me like that well you guys
have the high quality [ __ ] we got like
the Amazon but we have inventory just in
case you get ripped or whatever they so
I we got doughnuts because I was gonna
do a meme I want to be like hey hey
Ethan have a taste of the doughnut and
let me know give me a review of it yeah
yeah but where they from cuz you know um
I was talking to the guy and Dunkin
Donuts on Hollywood Boulevard yeah and I
was like listen you know I'll buy from
you guys but the thing is I don't know
if all the Dunkin Donuts in this country
ray alright made the same way so I told
them where where do you guys make You
Duncan Owens he told me in a bakery I
was like that's why I think New York um
and he just spoke for me he told me in
New York I think they make them and
waited he said so you're saying not all
doughnuts are slamming yeah we're gonna
get a true slamming from you guys well I
think no I gotta know what's the story
with these doughnuts guys I mean they
look good yeah I don't know where'd you
guys get it on this is East Coast
East Coast don't these are East Coast
goes from where Dunkin Donuts do well
here's what I want to do here's what I
want to do okay if it sucks then you
just spit it out and you don't give it a
review or a spit it up and whatever on
the table right but if it's great then I
want the genuine I forget about it yeah
you try whatever looks good and let me
know how does it taste
what do you think feeling it
how's that doughnut taste
[Applause]
oh yeah
you know who wrote that it was uh but
they're our first episode and we left it
there ever since special message I guess
the other do you want to do is landing I
don't know I didn't spit that out to
elegantly that's how good what's wrong
you know what's wrong you know what I
never got about the slamming means like
if it's so good why do you spit it out
we went out we won a really really
affirm you know two people the
communicating the goodness of it is
because you have the whole doughnut to
eat just that one bite exactly you spit
out how was there how was the what is it
slamming you know yeah what's the
philosophy behind it like you take me
into that I mean a whole life we've been
eating good food and we just like to
call the slamming so you've been doing
it for a while the slamming it's not
just doughnuts it's you know whenever we
go into restaurant whenever we go into
restaurants with our friends uh like um
our friends would look at us weird
because they they wouldn't know what's
coming like me and my brother really
appreciate food you know right we don't
take granted yeah and like when we taste
like yeah when we taste like food like
steak chicken french fries like we would
we would tell like the people how good
it is you know like we let the world
know the chef yeah that's it simple
that's beautiful like did you were you
guys surprised by how like how much that
slamming mean blew up
it's been hearing you really don't know
what's gonna take off yeah close kiss
that Mike oh yeah
I said I said you really never know
what's gonna take off on then on the
internet so it's just everything happens
in the weirdest way yeah like you think
something's gonna go um the way you
envision and blur those changes it's a
whole new meme dude the slamming is one
my favorite things people were
legitimately like freaked out in that
video funny one you guys made we got
another one coming was that anyone like
a new leg slamming they don't they don't
new your honour's
they like to like put it so what yeah I
mean they don't put effort into it yeah
that's exciting you guys unlisted that
video right or am I mistaken
oh yeah didn't you guys upload and then
you took it down what happened I think
no it's not private around this is what
happened yeah it was like a hot name I
think it it went on now where main town
over is it on our main channel or I
think it went on our main channel and we
were like wait is it on I mention mm-hmm
or is it on all the channel now it's on
the other channel yeah I think your
wires on the main yeah no what happened
why we put it on private yeah and then
we didn't want the mean to keep going
you didn't like the mean no I felt like
the longest time I didn't know what I
mean was I'm so new to this mean world
yeah I don't know what it is okay but
like right now I'm starting to get it
get get what it is embrace it I mean so
you you removed it cuz you were like you
just felt like people were making fun of
you guys and it wasn't coming off well
yeah that's okay it's fun a lot of the
things we do is link
I got it but it's meant to be funny but
I guess maybe people were taking it the
wrong way
yeah cuz I think I think what people
thought was we were making fun of food
and we would spit it out oh yeah so
that's why we kind of like yeah it would
be taking the wrong way yeah from a lot
of people got it you guys heard these
songs like Ethan trap berry and all this
[ __ ] yeah I heard one of them so good on
Soundcloud mix I notice you guys have
like when you scream slamming plays
you're gonna lose your voice it requires
it yeah I notice you guys have erased
other pranks before or like the one that
comes to - like the kidnapping one yeah
yeah but there were so many theories
about why you guys are raised yeah and I
think it'd be really interesting to to
hear from you guys like what why we
delete it
yeah I was getting a lot of hate okay
really yeah what about bad PR is good PR
kind of thing you don't wear no like I'm
so new to this my brother it's my
brother's idea to start this channel hmm
I don't want to do it I'm gonna be
straight out on it's like I'm just so
curious and so many things I follow my
efforts you know I'm saying so it's it's
my brother's idea I was a gamer before
this oh really yes I would travel to
different places and what game I'll call
the duty I was playing it competitively
yeah oh [ __ ] yeah that's what other [ __ ]
are you interested in if not videos oh
well now it's like it's like I'm just
following my efforts because one things
one things about it you know so I'm
taking advantage of the momentum yeah
yeah absolutely I mean you guys have
done well with the with a lot of the
stuff you made it's been good and
there's gonna be a lot more stuff we're
gonna make and do 10 times but
I hope guys stay tuned which channel
mony tea
oh just even bigger things we got and I
wanna know I want people to know where
they they don't they'll know don't know
it's good I'm just gonna fall from the
sky you guys are gonna see obviously the
truth always comes out but we rather cuz
we're building a couple things we'd
rather show you then tell you
okay sure totally so you're and you're
the guy that was in the videos and
making pranks and doing all this from
the beginning yeah it was like three
years ago I was always like um like
filming videos from my iphone trolling
around right people I would be pranking
people like I would go and dance in
front of them do push-ups you know and
on I had it I had an idea for YouTube
like three years ago like with two other
friends and we started this YouTube
channel called rock TV remember yeah a
lot of people know it's by the name rock
TV yeah they're like yo it's the oddball
when we're walking in the you know hoods
or whatever it wouldn't be like you know
is the oddball was like no but um yeah I
had this and my brother just happened to
be like sitting on the couch chilling
there and we started uh we started this
channel called Ock TV where it was
basically comedy skits mm-hmm not pranks
or social experiment and on and my
brother was like yo yet bound to join
you know he told me that yeah I told him
you eat - yeah down so whatever I just
go with the flow
yeah he would just always be down for
anything and he he said yeah let's go so
was that with Dennis Dennis Dennis does
Dennis see TV it has his own thing yeah
so we always help each other film with
the cameras like we started we started a
week beforehand and like we weren't
going viral in our videos but um you
were all working together yeah like you
could see like the edits were so good um
and and what we were doing like the
trolls or the comedy skits we're so good
like Dennis was like damn these guys are
actually doing it let me let me hop on
you know from every ever since then one
side away
together it's actually crazy that you
you guys and Dennis started at the same
time in both your channels blue were
like pretty predominant channels and um
yeah from what I was saying like two
months and two months into YouTube we
had this idea of doing I'm the boss's
son you guys seen that video what is it
the boss's son oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah where we would go behind the
counter and yell at that yep what are
you saying go to work right you know
wait a new one like somewhat recently
right like a sequel I'm the boss's son
yeah yes so I'm the two kids that were
on our channel they don't want to do it
and they wanted the chance to go a
different route we were telling them
like trust me like this trust me I know
what to do right I know what people want
to see and um they said ah
we don't want to do it no more I was
like okay so me and my brother just
continued and just that one video went
viral which is is sitting on people mmm
the first sitting on people now when I
was born huh that was you guys is first
yeah yeah and it got onto worldstar was
it a hood prank no it was just sitting
on people out we went some old set on
the tray and [ __ ] yeah okay
we sat on people and then that video
went made world site and they were like
oh you know then we kind of like stepped
up the game and did did stuff that
nobody would want to do that's why we
went into the yeah and made worldstar
every single week wow you guys were so
prolific on worldstar yeah that's
basically what gave us a momentum
interesting do you make do you have like
an account on worldstar people just
repost it no people repos okay it's a
whole nother world
I'm not deep into that world you guys
are when you're doing pranks you guys
ever worry about like bothering people
or are you just there to make like as
good as content as you can um like um
say that again
you ever worry about like bothering
people or are you just like you know I'm
just here to make a video not killing it
I mean the way the way I look at it I
don't know how he looks at it but the
I look at it as like I'm shocking
people's minds you know maybe they
hadn't had this experience and in such a
long time you're helping them you're
doing something for them I'm helping
that's a good way to think about it so
when you sit on someone's lap in the
subway
you're like help you may be annoyed
right now but I just gave you a shot of
exactly they need that energy right
because it takes like that takes a
second someone's like like it's
something differently if someone sat on
you yeah you would start thinking so
much right that's a lot of energy right
there yeah you're right I mean you're
right I would be I would be pissed my
adrenaline would be pumping I would lose
a fight to anyone but maybe someone
bigger have you ever
yeah I'm about your experience not often
but we had to go to like some brutal
neighborhoods to get those and the hoods
you want those reaction yeah were you
asked like it's gotta be scary yeah very
nerve-wracking mm-hmm it's not a
pleasant experience it gets here yeah hi
starts beating in you're helping
yourself yeah by the same logic yes know
it yeah I honestly you feel like it's an
adrenaline junkie bang um like an
extreme sport pranking black people half
half cuz there's limits there's limits
right yeah you know yeah it gotta be a
balance
you can't go too far and and you can't
um go too low because if you go too
highest like there's like so many
precautions and if you go too low um
it's corny right yeah for sure
why is it what what is it about the hood
the hood yeah going into the hoods yeah
that was like to be honest I don't know
is just an idea that popped into the
head and just like the moment it's
something it's something people weren't
willing to do I would ask my friends yo
would you go do this you know pull up
someone's
and he was like are you crazy yeah and
then I was like I told my brother it was
like why don't we go pull up people's
kids anyway sagging we want to dump them
or help them out you know sighted you -
yeah I like those videos um years ago I
was later I was 21 hmm what is it like
is it is it something like I mean
obviously there's some racial like
perspective to be made there cuz you
guys are going in the hood and you're
pranking like I mean specifically black
people right so what's the like what is
what's going on there there's nothing
going on there it's just um the way I
look at it is like um I put myself in
someone else's shoe and I ask myself um
like like people always wonder what will
happen whenever people always ask
themselves what would happen if you do
something in the hood you know what and
we were the first ones to test that out
okay I don't think we were the first
ones but I think we pioneered like a
whole different there was a whole yeah
yeah four months straight I think it
lasted four months or something I don't
think it was quick thing I don't think
it was necessarily a racial because all
our videos have different people in them
but for the hoods like we would we would
do the same types of like reactions but
with other people and we wouldn't get
the same reaction interesting you know I
mean maybe we should have added one of
those reactions and so people when
you're saying you would prank like non
black people and they wouldn't they
wouldn't their reactions weren't as good
ya know some of their reactions were you
know some are good yeah not as good a
cop stuff on my job on your joy yeah I
think I think that was on Kobe homeys
very did you prank him um no we we
pretended like we broke out a fight with
a bunch of people and we screaming loud
and then the cops got em all stepped on
your face yes that's that's pretty
gnarly
yeah so you don't you don't think it's
like a it's a racial thing more of just
like a danger thing you're you see
yourself as doing something dangerous
yeah yeah something
strange about like this thing of like
black people giving the best reactions
um not not just black people yeah it's a
whole bunch yeah for sure
I guess there's other yeah fair enough I
have a question
a non sequitur here for you guys has
Soflo ever [ __ ] you guys over and
because I know the answer is yes what
when and what was it no he never now I'm
just kidding I had Joey salads on and he
was saying so flow post my videos on
Facebook all the time he doesn't pay me
so close so flow was very sweet kid you
gotta top that he's a he's a lot of cool
so you guys have no like Sultan we had
good time sometimes were like let's
bring back the memory let's go back to
cruise crew just now is like too busy so
I know he's done some crazy [ __ ] he saw
him like [ __ ] bras I don't know what
he does nice book he's doing weird and
what cuz we got him on the podcast yeah
and he was like he's just on the level
selling bras like importing bras from
China for like 20 cents in strap or
anything wow I think I seen something
yeah yeah yeah he produces them fits the
China people yes it's like garbage right
he's comedy so flow quality you guys are
good friends man
you guys have his back that Joe Salas
was like [ __ ] that guy no actually she
wasn't like that Joey I think I think
it's like a back-and-forth play around
thing I don't think of it too much yeah
word by the way Joey wasn't like that he
was just like I like so Flo he just owes
me money
they both live in a later yeah yeah I
broke her to peace between them this is
so floating money and they both been on
the podcast so I got him on the phone
and we [ __ ] worked it out do we
we brokered the peace that's I was a
proud moment for me and this in the show
in general so I want to ask you guys
something
and correct me if I'm not slamming yeah
I scream so much man I'm losing my voice
does slam is get you yeah you need it
cuts both ways right you try to tell the
world know the cuts cuts inside my wood
in it if you need more just yell at him
he's there he's asleep he's literally
just our slave shoutout to Ian yeah yeah
Ian the beverage I know you're [ __ ] up
back there whatever the water would it
would it seems like Ethan's the crazy
one and Mo is like the calming presence
like he's trying to he's trying to like
tame the hurricane like I think back to
like um the beach pranks and you're and
you're just like a [ __ ]
uncontrollable force and Moe's like I
feel like you're trying to hold it down
is that kind of an accurate description
of you guys relationship it goes it's
like both ways it's unknown to be honest
it's all I know like it's just I can't
really explain it cuz uh there's
different like characters you know mmm
but in real life you got there's not
like anything like hold me back dad no
when we were younger yeah do you see
much guy I wasn't sure suck but you guys
are [ __ ] cool you're really calm
though it's nice to meet you guys and
finally the way he was we're glad to be
here
yeah it's really cool manifested men did
it manifested finally you know we
actually hired a set designer to come in
that's what I was thinking like you need
something like that we also at first it
was kind of different and we moved
things around it looks really good
thanks man thank you
we we basically told a set designer were
like I love Howard Stern set rip it off
mm and she did that
that's my she had this first blueprint
she's like this is good right and I'm
like no you have to read right you got
it has a good artists copy the great
artists steal
thank you so hey I want to go back like
what's the craziest thing that ever
happened when I went filming one your
guys's videos mmm crazy yeah I mean if
that cop one is there anything crazier
that happened with your pranks in the
hood or anything um I could say like two
things
sure mm-hmm something that's not really
crazy but we got arrested
oh we me while doing a prank yeah me
even and Dennis mmm it was Dennis's
video he was trying to drink he had an
alcohol bottle but with water and
checking in public and the cop arrested
us
and uh put us in like behind bars for
like two hours and we left all these
water yeah you know what the cop knew
who you were when we were brought into
the precinct all the cops were laughing
and I was asleep it's a prank
and then the Sarge was like you're not
leaving no way I was like this guy's
funny then like cops like dying the door
I was like are you singing Restless its
water water and then they just you know
cuz is that a meal to drink water every
ball no certainly not but I guess they
they have like I mean I'm not a [ __ ]
lawyer
what do I know I don't think so I don't
think the all day part was one time like
we were walking to film a video and then
um like we passed by a park and then
like like these people like we're like
yo those are the praying boys go get go
get it go get it I was like go get what
yo gonna jump you know I think they had
like a well done I promise you we rinse
like we're like come on let's walk I
whispered now once we got a little bit
Mohawk beer in yo that's scary yeah well
you guys have done pranks where someone
pulled a gun on you yeah it was that
real yeah well that's qualifies that's
right yeah but um that's why we stopped
doing them I was gonna ask you guys were
famous for them why'd you stop
because enters every every time we
walked on the streets I swear you're
scared okay because people knew you guys
they'd seen your videos you see what you
were up to yeah like we were so
recognizable like we had the glasses the
short hair the nerdy look so and here
yeah you guys are completely different
right yeah he had a different look and
then just people would just always look
at us like it wasn't going too good to
parrot you guys got paranoid paranoid
yeah it's not exactly what happened
today today yeah oh it's probably like
different reaction today right if
someone recognizes you well it's it's
different yeah we had couple people
every now and then you get recognized
yeah yeah is it good or is it usually
good it's that's always good yeah anyway
yeah like the hood the hood prank fans
like faded away yeah it's okay yeah it's
been a long time yeah what would you say
to like a black person who lived in the
hood was like man these guys are racist
they come into the hood they're doing
pranks on us we tell them look at our
videos man we have a variety of people
that we bring weird yeah cool
so listen we're gonna take a quick break
we're gonna roll our sponsors all right
gonna do some copy reads we're gonna get
some more coffee some more water stay
tuned guys we'll be back in exactly
three minutes gonna read and thank our
sponsors guys thank you so much head on
over to h2 h3 shop calm and subscribe at
twitch.tv for such a dream productions
we'll be back in three minutes guys with
the Bradbury boys let's go thank you to
our sponsor videoblocks Cobb slash h3
the best what is it stock photos stock
photos and videos guys usually you need
a stock photo you need a template you go
to like stock whatever dot-com and it's
like five hundred dollars for man
sitting on a park bench feeding pigeons
belly button lint
no videoblocks you get a year's
subscription unlimited downloads for
$149 a year unlimited video blocks comm
/h 3 you won't regret it I live by it
ela swears by it we use it all the time
if you watched our videos you probably
saw their footage in our videos 100% you
did thank you for that backup EULA so
good to have you back look at this go to
go to video blocks type sunrise type
type moon look at all this beautiful
creamy unlimited downloadable content
where's my mouse goddammit mm-hmm here
look at this [ __ ] you popped that in the
mail of a spoof a total spoof I know
your footage doesn't look this good it's
gonna be completely out of place but
that's funny look at this unlimited
downloads guys go to video blocks
combats vib EOB okay I think CK you know
how to spell video blocks calm slash h3
thank you to our sponsor there and we've
got me on DS you guys already know me on
DS they make the most comfortable
underwear jackets sweaters t-shirts and
socks and today introducing a new clip
for all my fetish boys out there this is
a wonderful sock did you know me undies
make socks socks are underwear
of course they make it you got ankle
socks boom ela loves this so soft I gave
it like just fell through my fingers the
softest sock look at this cool stuff
guys me undies the most comfortable pair
of underwear and now socks you will ever
own 100% satisfaction guaranteed if you
don't love the dank socks the dang
undies guess what you get your money
back it's easy as that it's risk free
capiche
right now me undies has an exclusive
offer just for our listeners get 20% off
your first order and free shipping nice
that's a legit
mandis is so sure you're gonna love
their underwear and socks that will give
you a hundred percent satisfaction
guarantee simply order a pair if you
don't love it get a full refund it's a
no-brainer guys give me a break
go to my undies dot-com / h3 it's 20%
off just for our viewers because they
know the Fupa kings the Fupa troopers
are worth it and a footprint Queens
Koopa Queens I so great having you back
so put some socks on the Fupa Troopa
feet that deserved the best thank you my
undies go to me undies calm /h 3 for 20%
off if you're in the market for some
stock footage consider hitting up video
box.com such a true and if you're in the
market furs any underwear from A to Z go
to Mandy's comm / h3 thank you for
supporting us thank you
let's get back to Brad Berry Farms and
pick some fresh ones welcome back
everybody here with the Bradbury boys
that's right
so are you guys is this like the premium
[ __ ] because I bought them on Amazon for
like I don't know I thought I was
getting the good one but you guys you
this is the good [ __ ] yeah what do you
buy that stuff it's from I think China
really oh yeah how much it cost per one
cuz that pear one yeah
those are expensive right yeah like a
hundred bucks yeah about that's the good
[ __ ] man I couldn't find where to buy
that so that's like for the performers
yeah but you have to worry about it
coming in a month ISM how fast Joyce
came in few days Amazon Prime yeah gotta
be prime that prime twitch bribes
subscribe for free by linking your
twitch and Amazon Prime guys tell me who
was your inspiration for for doing
pranks like moe I guess it was your idea
right to start making videos so what
inspired you do you have an inspiration
o to start a YouTube channel
yeah to make videos or make pranks in
general um I just idol I just always had
this idea in my head where on like I
always loved creating videos content
and I knew if I would do it it would
work because like I'm I'm that
competitive type of person where I used
to use a what's that software cinema4d
when I was like 13 doing clones on that
and stuff then I went into After Effects
and all better and I learned that just
by filming stuff from my phone and just
playing around and I was like I love to
do this like I don't look I don't love
to do it but I like to do it and you're
good at it
I was curious to see where I would take
sure are you the one that does all the
crazy like after effects on the
spider-man Elsa videos oh it's like
different people that should stop
lightning bolts and [ __ ] do you guys
have a favorite prankster on YouTube
some of the you wash your like this
guy's dope ordinary pranks do all
pranksters like hate each other
sometimes I get that vibe the favorite
prankster yeah no I don't hate nobody or
maybe not even on YouTube but generally
I like that honestly denying yeah I
never looked at pranks is like um I'll
just curious so um I never really used
to like watching my videos after we
filmed them and I never used to like
watching anyone else you know what I'm
saying yeah I could develop and focus on
my craft for sure that Flanders it was
it was just this simple you recorded
video and add prank at the end viral
prankster I'm not considered a prankster
dude I don't I don't you knows following
the yeah yeah I like you know I see
what's going on and you know it works
well that kind of explains the the next
question I have for you yeah because
pranks was a huge passing phenomenon
yeah and you guys say that you follow
the fat and you do it and you do what's
good what's popular so that kind of
leads me to the the spider-man Elsa fat
okay but you never know the pranks might
come back believe me we're so sure
listen cyclical right dislike you know
this both of you know this like we're so
early on social media you never know
what's gonna come back
and be big again tonight yeah sure to
actually to tell you know I think pranks
could come make a comeback I think they
were just a lot of potentially yes
saturation low quality and people lost
faith and it became like a meme you know
like what [ __ ] YouTube pranks rocks
to you man
change the game hey yeah thanks for that
appreciate you yeah I mean yeah I feel
like you like our fates have been
intertwined like in a way we've all been
collaborating for a walk TV you guys
were huge and we were and we were just
starting out for yeah yeah we when we
first start found you guys channel you
guys were in doing pranks on the hood
yeah we're huge yet over million subs
which was a crazy yeah we hit a quick
and yeah that just explains to you mm
that explains to respect the ground
hustle thanks I appreciate that just
explains like you guys have it to would
appreciate the grind the hustle oh yeah
yeah mm-hm
like a lot of people think like uh we're
like always like joking around in real
life but they don't see what's behind
the scenes you know yeah you guys are
dedicated is no question but I they're
no they don't know we wake up 6:00 in
the morning to do stuff you know we only
sleep 60 that way I look at it the way I
look at it is like it's it's just
enterprise I love enterprise business
mm-hmm how'd you guys think how'd you
dream up the spider-man Elsa thing like
how the and I and I and I admire the
enterprise as you said because I'm sure
that was extremely lucrative but you
guys were like really successful at
cenchrea venom simple curiosity
curiosity curiosity let's was doing one
thing that lets all other and just
exploded you know why are you laughing
laughing Frank I mean contagious yawning
Frank we did that too I made a comment
you see that no yeah I made a copy we
did a video where we were like
it's funny what young you know ya know
it's [ __ ] up why I don't know why it's
a mystery of this world
oh yeah and so you guys like tell me you
walk me through the spider-man else's
[ __ ] cuz that is fascinating for me
right yeah where you add when people
found out that it was you guys doing it
um let me see some what super sleuth the
[ __ ] yes because they found like you
converted one year older channels to the
spider-man [ __ ] but what was I mad boy
reaction mmm when you've won we gotta
take it back it was like a year ago
since then yeah that's right that's
right
yeah to be honest I was it's just so
frustrating man
you can't escape ya know because like
you're building it and then um you
really don't know who's behind watching
everything like monitoring everything is
this like Oh at the time like there was
so much things going on on the Internet
today and then they start watching
channels obviously we made a mistake
yeah we filmed it in a house we lived in
no well I mean do you regret it but it
was frustrating I'll tell you why I did
get mad cuz um it's just it's just going
back to when I was saying it shocks your
mind man so but at the same time it's
like part of the journey so you just
gotta be like you're saying that people
were shocking your mind in this case
I'll just the event like the whole thing
was brain shocking yeah yeah it was it
was pretty nutty the thing is I didn't
even really know about the Spira else's
[ __ ] barely until I started hearing you
guys were doing it we started putting it
together so yeah yeah but it was you
gotta wait the wait this would have
never happened we try to keep a low key
for the longest buzz just whatever you
could take this and then after um we
just didn't care
yo yo watch the plague yo just forget
about it you know the gold coin all
right
we would do scenes in the artery I know
I saw spider-man it's so funny so at a
certain point cos will [ __ ] it
yeah but on this wouldn't ever happened
if it wasn't for him like he's are you
he got me into it yeah um I was I was
like sleeping in bed and I like he was
more curious than me is that yo come
check this out we gotta go we gotta go
get something to eat and talk about this
was like it was like it was like 3:00 in
the morning inspiration strikes yeah I
was like this I was like no bro let's do
it another day and then if we kept
arguing for 30 minutes to my left and
met up he was right yeah I was like whoa
this makes sense yeah but the first
month or two nothing it's not so strange
other like YouTube algorithm it's just
one day they're like but I love it love
it
with this you got it you gotta keep
putting one on one together it's a
gamble sometimes you keep grinding and
like it pays off you can't learning what
works and what what works cuz the
algorithm keeps changing so when you
guys hit it off with the spider-man
else's [ __ ] were you making more money
than you were with the pranks did you
buy another yeah we don't we don't we
don't I don't we don't spend money on my
stuff you know yeah we don't we drive
regular tights that's that's smart yeah
we don't the way I've always heard that
kid's content is super super [ __ ]
lucrative I don't want to know I'm not
asking I'm just saying is it can you
confirm that it's super lucrative cool
kobe no kids cause like spider-man
else's [ __ ] it's something that will
just mess with your brain yeah if you're
thinking about see because it's just a
whole different niche and you got it
really like just you're confirming am i
confirming
I'm just saying like it's it's a very uh
lucrative different you know it's it's
you're saying it's way better than like
pranks in the hood it depends on what
you want it's a balanced man really
think about it pranks you're branding
yourself yeah
the other thing yeah you know I'm saying
you're just you're grinding there look
at look at some of the roles like some
of the major actors took and how he
would like they would take like weird
roles and skull viral you know it's just
weird something better but you don't you
don't regret doing it I mean clearly you
guys shut up I'm gonna I don't I'm gonna
say something I never regret anything
okay very good that's great I don't want
to I don't want to be old and be like
damn I wish I'd done that yes well you
don't regret like I mean maybe he's not
regrets not the right word but maybe you
think like oh I wish maybe I got a new
how a different house and did it there
something no because no because you know
why once they've got damnit mo it's
getting hot in there
let's get Spidey out of this damn this
damn thing oh hey what else hmm
no worries we got another Bradbury in
the house what a bread maybe so listen
nice shirt yeah you looking good so Joey
salads says that 99% of all pranks on
YouTube are fake right do you agree with
that probably exaggerating yeah well did
you guys ever fake pranks yeah like oh
well I mean like what not a lot not a
lot of them well at what point what
stuff was real yeah good stuff I could
stop you know what really I gotta say um
Oh Mike check sorry I gotta say you guys
saw like um there was people who were
saying like the prank hoods were fake
for a minute and I was like what like
I'm one I'll call it a fake prank when I
see it but when I saw people being like
Activa hood pranks are fake I was like
what
that should see it real sell to me its
haters out there you know what it is
I'll tell you what it is we pioneered
the genre right mmm so obviously um when
you pioneer something everyone else
starts leeching off of it right oh they
can they here he says you can I was
saying I was saying we pioneered at
genre right so whenever you pioneer
something other people start leeching
off sure and a whole bunch of other
people started doing it yeah and
whenever they do it who does it go to us
you know I'm saying what do you mean if
some people faked it then you get also
under the same you get the same scrutiny
yes exactly so when you guys did fake a
prank like why what was it about this
particular bravery like man let's fake
this one or what purpose to really to
really get a message across because um
it would have to be done a certain way
like all day helping the homeless stuff
is always fake no no not always
no any of them no those are the ones
I've always suspected as fake because
the reaction is always like way too
inspirational nah but some social
experiments where fake them okay yeah
like the Craigslist yeah which one was
the crazy one did they removed
yeah all right the kidnapping one hell
yeah we only had that up for an hour
that sure is funny we must allow that
one I was like to do I mean it's yeah
and what I said listen I'm telling you
like like um I get these weird feelings
man like if we left it up it would have
guns very big but it would have like we
would have ate all that hate I mean
leave such a long time the bigger it
gets obviously
man YouTube shows that everyone was it
tough it's aligned though because you
guys are pranksters so it's your bread
and butter right that so that one like
there was no real issue with like the
police or anything because I remember
watching that one I was like - this [ __ ]
is [ __ ] crazy
yeah did you guys actually did anyone
call the police cuz you guys were like
straight-up kidnapping someone in broad
daylight for which one
yeah the Craig's they call yeah yeah I
think I think one of them called the
cops like I think I think it showed like
a person in the car yeah if you and the
video was up someone reuploading dude it
was super convincing like I actually
wasn't sure about the realness yeah but
we really wanted to get a message across
like if people use stuff like on
Craigslist it happens to my friends my
friends want to buy something they get
robbed I promise you yeah
it's all for ya so my friends like would
go with like three people to be
protected you know sure it happens he
almost got said yeah my friend almost
lost that you guys are in New Jersey a
Craigslist New Jersey's gnarly and um
and uh Brooklyn New York
even worse or even crazier maybe
Brooklyn depending on the neighborhood
obviously William is very very dangerous
someone might sell you a $10 coffee no
Bedford Stuyvesant Flatbush what's that
place we used to wake anybody is it a
bad neighbor no in the supermarket Oh
Williamsburg oh yeah oh and that's what
you get that's a very dangerous some
some hipsters beard might rub on you
there
suppose my scratch yeah like blades I'm
telling you I forgot so in the world of
pranksters a lot of people always
accusing each other of stealing pranks
so my question is like do you guys
follow the the ecosystem of pranksters
do you have an opinion of who's like the
worst prankster that rips off everybody
I don't know I don't you know you guys
are sweet I love you guys
well usually you have someone in here
and they're like oh yeah [ __ ] I love you
too but you guys are actually nice guys
man you don't say [ __ ] about anybody I
think that speaks for that sky koala
that's a high character thing I mean you
know anything about Joey that's why I
like him because he's a Carrie yeah yes
like we hang out he brings positive
energy he is he honestly is a nice
[ __ ] guy he's a solid head yeah you
guys see this vitaliy video just like
coke fueled rage the metallic which
wanted everyone or he's like I'm the
ultimate prankster and it calls out all
the other big pranksters by name he
called you guys out in it through yeah
let me see haven't see anything
man you guys are [ __ ] don't spend any
time on YouTube it seems like what you
guys seriously didn't see this here
deleted it
no guy he went to this coke filter
frenzy and was talking [ __ ] on every
world that chn know someone reuploaded
it like he took it down let me show you
here watch he talk [ __ ] i time step
where he talks about Kobe person and you
guys know you I think I seen that yeah
he looks like a mania oh I'll tell you
why I'll tell you why he did that
I know I know these things you want to
watch sure you want to watch what he
said about us can you turn it up down
[Music]
he's getting there
anyway he talks [ __ ] on Kobe and then he
talks about you next you took all my
[ __ ] titles you tried to be [ __ ]
tough running around Brooklyn full black
people bands down
surprise even if you ask strangers for
directions pick up your favorite such a
balls-up your wrath and get the [ __ ] off
youtube whoa no he's ain't he's not just
you guys he's everybody no no I'll tell
you what yeah what happened look at the
way he's talking play it play for two
seconds go ahead
sure break limitless you tried to save
any think that's the way he really talks
oh you [ __ ] I think he's on drugs
he's not on drugs
at that time he did a he did a video
where the Bulls step on his jaw it broke
his jaw and he was hospitalized I
remember that so you got a really think
deep this guy it really shocked his mind
I think he went I don't want to say
crazy but I don't I don't think he was
in the right state of mind on
painkillers exactly so so you don't you
don't know what he was thinking at the
time
Ethan you're a great guy dude you're
always fine that good you guys are
always looking for the best parts of
people you know justifying this really
awful video yeah that's what happened
you just did some coke I thought he was
on a coke no I remember that I'm not him
he was hot this is after you think he
regretted he's like man I don't actually
hate all this did he delete it yeah yeah
there you go
he looks like completely insane yeah he
wasn't he wasn't aware huh damn you want
to keep playing it yeah there's a part
he has a part about Joey sells and Kobe
I'll play a part for Joe just because I
mean Joe [ __ ] disrespected my mother
you wanted to [ __ ] her you want to [ __ ]
her
I'm gonna [ __ ] her I will cut off your
[ __ ] dick shoving your mouth make you
[ __ ] chew on it and I'll [ __ ] you
chew you love me [ __ ] angry I think
it's the angriest person I've ever seen
in my life
man character yeah you can what do you
guys think of Italia I've never met him
I think all Kobe Kobe Kobe Kobe here he
met Kobe met him in New York City well
before Kobe was on YouTube Oh Papa bless
oh thanks doc Papa bless you with your
soda pop that's true yeah get me a soda
pop whirring you won but we were running
late because what is it soda pop so do
you know the story is that means
everything
then all right you're in dude then
you're in the matrons everyday in the
main matrix there's this video about
Papa John and his son Beau and their
pizza mansion yeah and he called he said
let's get some soda pops instead of like
soda and it cracked me up so sorry pops
thank you in in hustling you guys I'm
good it's ice-cold I'm good I'm good we
appreciate it
Cheers the bus
yeah we switched over here this is that
Diet Coke yeah nice I can't handle that
regular [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] obese like one
cookie away if you like diabetes good
man do I wait you fatter before you
can't tell on camera but what I kind of
like yeah are you in the gym I know I
don't like I don't like the gym I
exercise at home you know what you know
I've an elliptical machine and push-ups
do you know what you need to do you need
to get on like a diet which is very
challenging but that's the main thing to
diet and like I'm about that you know
it's [ __ ] up what kind of diet what do
you guys do you guys like per unit are
you still being like bigger than this
yeah I just like buff you know I go
heads north I go heavy on the
Stairmaster you know the same as it the
hardest cardio 1,500 calories every day
and then Koli yeah Kobe Kobe is higher
than wedding bullet Kobe's does 2,000
calories that's insane yeah like you
walk in the gym and there's a puddle I
promise you and then people that would
look at them like these guys are mania
how long does it take to burn 2,000
Callaghan out Oh an hour an hour and
five minutes and if I'm running super
intense six I tried it for 18 minutes I
was dying if you know what 2,000
calories on the stem a so you know
that's brutal
so what do you eat afterwards a lot of
spaghetti and meatballs some carbs
obviously come around heart what's your
favorite food me like what's most flames
you said you guys are very you like that
Italian
I mean yesterday we had some Mexican
food what up
I felt lighter right yeah I think it was
authentic Mexican food so that was
slamming that was yeah so your favorite
food I like my no [ __ ] you look used to
eat that [ __ ] so frequently it's not
authentic oh god they found like what
was it cold on it like Salmonella summer
don't die ether were last burrito of
your life at Chipotle I bet as you know
there's like a South Park did a joke
about Chipotle that like you shoot your
brains out
well it's real I [ __ ] diarrhea all day
boy they say stuff and these shows in it
it's real yes but I guess that's a good
weight loss program right diarrhea yeah
that works
yeah if you don't want to be I mean only
if you consistent with it right you got
to stick to what you guys do gotta come
out liquid right you know there's that
that water weight yeah you know this is
a complete I love this fact this trivia
Louis Armstrong famous jazz musician
wrote a diet book and his technique for
losing weight was to take laxatives and
[ __ ] his brains out don't you do that
really that really makes you [ __ ] your
brains up laxatives yeah
designed by doctors make you [ __ ] your
brains out how like if you take like a
dose of air or whatever how it is like
you [ __ ] for the whole day I actually I
don't know I've never actually gotten
down that rabbit hole no it's just a fan
of his work well tell me about it
actually good [ __ ] all theirs are just
like once it's like when you're just
just squirting you're slamming can I
should be slamming or just food can [ __ ]
like a diarrhea be slamming or just film
depends like how the kind of smell it
you know right like never like that
smell gotta contain good yeah like like
whenever like you know
why you wait right whenever he blows
fights like I would you guys you guys
have a close relationship man I admire
that
I thought me Neal were close when I fart
she clears the room why I have some
often I have some some good days all
right so you guys rebranded from awk or
is that Ock or awk TV it's a CVP so you
guys rebranded from octave E to mo ne T
yeah I wouldn't know why we called it
off TV there's no reason for that name I
don't even know why we did it
subliminally so what made you guys
rebrand from Hawk TV - moaning - we
thought it would be better Brendan yeah
because because when I would be walking
someone would call me yuck like way I
kind of thought about that yeah
basically rebrand get your name in there
yeah let's say let's say let's say your
channel is called or your your channels
called um hehe productions though yeah
how do people say he is it : oh so yeah
actually the origin story is that we
wanted to call it hehehe because it's
our initials combined but it was taken
so we did H 3 H 3 o h e 18 yeah like
maybe because lo bizarre it's a little
unusual I thought I thought it was like
so so um like I was gonna ask you people
and whenever you get recognized people
call you yo hehehe no they always say
the name
yeah yeah all right or well no they'll
say like yo its h2 h3 like right like
you'll walk by in the back oh it's h3 h3
alright alright but they how do you
handle that our fans are it's a very
personal thing so they all I think most
of them know they're loyal right bust
until you make a video they don't you
they don't like then they'll come to
your house and burn it down no way I for
the most part I cut when you have like
uh such us like strong engaged fanbase
it really cuts both ways
mmm-hmm when you're when you're hitting
it good they love you and then when you
have like an off month your videos are a
little subpar it's like [ __ ] brutal
it sucks I don't like it all by the way
congratulations for the law oh yeah
thank you guys
yeah that felt good how long sorry so
now basically uh people could like
basically we re upload and compensate or
something not re-upload I like what my
reaction okay because commentary right
okay yeah all right that's that's
powerful it was yeah I'm really I'm
really drained yeah energy we liked what
you did for the community what's the
opposite of slamming opposite of
slamming I know what do you what do you
think the opposite of slamming I don't
know disgusting this backwards okay hit
on sport mode this was originally like
learn life life like like you don't like
yeah stop yeah like you know bro you
want to go chill life what does that
stop me busy
yeah oh I didn't okay so learn life
means busy
it could mean different things like my
feels really no not busy like
like I don't know like tonight
too bad too bad yeah so that's what that
is yeah you know origin story you know
can you like move that thing on the
floor my life too bad
learn life no I move that no life it's
called because you say like your death
yeah something or is this like your
guyses me and where is this something
that's in the world oh it's a sign that
in the world but we we um you push the
next located you innovated on it yeah
you guys are innovators man I want to
say just just that like yeah anyway uh
just going back to the fan thing like
yeah it's it you got to appreciate it
but it's it is frustrating sometimes
when it cuts both ways when like they
get upset and you're like I'm doing my
best out here yeah YouTube comments man
does it get to you I don't read them oh
but um if they're let me see if other
youtubers start talking about it in a
bad way then we have to look at the
comment I feel like YouTube comments
like um like people just want to comment
stuff just to maybe get a response like
I don't think they legit when they
comment stuff like that it's very
confusing like if you read all your
comments and take it personal and like
you're not you can't you're not gonna go
anyway you have to really just focus on
slamming you got to really just focus on
your own good energy sometimes I have a
hard time but you're right you got a you
you said it you really can't focus on
that trust me yeah we're all in this
together gets on put on the producing
Moorea good content and whatever you're
good at yeah so for the longest time you
guys denied your involvement in
spider-man else' like people to ask you
like I don't know what you're talking
about are you guys even like I remember
when I called you with post Malone and
by the way I do owe you guys an apology
for that because that was kind of [ __ ]
up how we like put you on
spot yeah but I did sir that wanted to
reach out to you guys and have anyway
yeah no and I and there was more that we
cut out because I wanted to you know
respect you guys privacy no we we
respect that because you know um like I
said we got to put our shoes in someone
else's and try to figure out what's
going on you know cuz I always like to
get into things like I like to
understand it like I told you I didn't
know what I mean was for me like it's
it's so frustrating I want to know what
this thing is you know that I'm Ethan
Bradberry was one of the biggest means
yeah a long time
yes like all the YouTube comments were
does Ethan I mean Brad lazy man so do
you will enlighten now that you do you
feel like you understand what I mean is
I'm getting at it I'm starting to get it
do you feel in mind or like what do you
mean like do you feel like your your
minds been elevate like yeah from
learning more about this yeah yeah sure
um I just think it brought you here
right yeah yeah I like that things
happen the weirdest ways you know yeah
so is is coming here today part of like
embracing the meme and learning about
what a meme is boys yeah I want to know
more about it right you have a question
for me um I want me to I do what made
you like what made you what was in your
head when uh you thought about I'm Ethan
Bradberry listen I'll answer him I'll
answer for him man curious answer
well there was something like so great
about that one shot when you guys were
walking together I think it was like the
smoke right and you said it so fast and
it doesn't sound like you either it's
like high pitch played again down it's
like no I think he was screaming it made
me for the engine was it was yeah yeah
Mike was probably like was yeah but like
you did it so fast and you did this
whole thing and you had like your you
know what whenever we're filming
whenever we're filming an intro like we
want to do it like we want to focus on
the biggest stuff in the video make sure
you know that was probably an accident
though
he said it but that's crazy weird how
things like no just came out like it was
amazing to you yeah it was magic I don't
know it's just me magic and people like
that we didn't expect it also to go so
big like it was even a video we made on
our second channel not even our main
channel but it like you never expected
you never expect what goes big trust me
we already go through that and people
won't know what we're talking about um
until they actually experience it you
know yeah it's just like so so I get
what you guys are coming from you so
what do you what do you guys think about
our of our videos were you ever mad at
me or upset or like man I was guy I was
that's fair um I think you just said
yeah because like I said I don't know
what a meme is and you kept going at it
and you kept building momentum so I was
like we thought me me me I was mad about
that pie I didn't know what a meme was
you weren't like you weren't necessarily
angry at me you're just like confused
yeah this whole world okay because I
think memes were like um that the whole
mean world that's been going on right
for such a long time yeah yeah that's
crazy
you guys are a welcome I think by the
way you guys are incredible I think
people are gonna be really happy to get
to know you guys personally this is I I
can speak for myself it's been great
yeah talk chatting with you guys and
getting to know you it's a great tool
man welcome to the main way course I
mean world is something else there's a
lot of weird things going on on it
that's true um that mean thing yeah yeah
well if you guys ever have any questions
about that
are you with me I guess like in some
ways yeah for sure it's an honor but you
guys are living its head to toe about
that there's like so so it's funny
though it's not like ya know it's funny
cuz I'm getting done this in yeah but
I'm saying like what's your intention
- like um do the whole mean thing from
the beginning no no it wasn't like I
mean we were just trying to make like no
not really like that designed I don't
think that's how that works right it's
you just make a video and then people
like this this part was yeah something
memorable so let's turn it into me like
I remember Colby person right he had
this what are you out of your mind and
we cut the guy out walking out and
yelling at the girl and we would put it
in all of our videos yeah
and so that he's like somebody was born
you edit that yeah
what what's left with premiere they'll
be promoted right well you like premiere
better than Final Cut yeah I just never
use Final Cut I never learned on it oh
yeah you use these computers nah we have
pcs at home I don't like it that stops
up yeah you play games right yeah [ __ ]
yeah but what kinda game pc yeah PC I
have a switch I like switch yeah you
don't blew my mind I've been playing I
tried playing which are three on the ps4
which yeah witcher 3 you know that game
the whole time yeah all right i heard
about hunt
what is it baseball it's like a RPG or
whatever okay it's a fantasy game but it
was [ __ ] lagging yeah like what the
[ __ ] is his [ __ ] good
it's a ps4 Oh are you yeah I usually
play on my PC because I'm like this
consoles can't even play their own damn
games what do you play um to be honest I
don't play anything but okay for like
four or five years of console gamer yeah
weird console Oh
Xbox whatever was on the circuit the
circuit is like MLG analogy yeah it's
all competitive or whatever it's the top
game time yeah cool yeah you ever win
any prizes you get it Steve in any
tournament ah little money on some some
website they shut down though yeah
that's so let's see here anyway
so I mean yeah I'm really happy you guys
came out here to pleasure it's been
[ __ ] dope I guess I'm all end of the
yeah yeah I want to get to that well you
guys you guys Twitter accounts are
pretty [ __ ] interesting oh yeah hell
yeah do you want to get me into them
here let me open this ghost the ghost
get me into the mind use you guys both
have similar let's go there you go
look at that so this is Pam if you're
reading this I love you yeah I love you
miss Thanks I love you too
good morning beautiful you down tonight
what does that mean like down with the
shits
does this are you trying to get some
cuties it's all trolling man I love it
so you're into meme [ __ ] yeah you're
you're really cute cool cool you're not
trying to [ __ ] wait did I write that no
this one here uh if you're asking about
that but you're not trying to [ __ ] are
you guys trying to [ __ ] with these
twitter i'm not judge god bless like oh
like with twitter no trying to put your
dick away into an email now only if its
Roybal raw no condom exact okay is that
how you and then I want to talk about
Sunset Park cuz that was like I guess
your guys is new enterprise it's done
now you guys haven't posted video there
and like - hell no it's not it hasn't
even begun okay because I just I assume
that because you haven't posted there in
a couple months it's it's actually
something you're working on yeah hell
yeah I'm gonna be the biggest so Sunset
Park if you guys don't know is like how
would you describe it Sunset Park yeah
it's just uh let me see it's best
friends who have the same vision who
want to create content together got it
simple
yeah honestly we like whatever whatever
I have envisioned on where it's gonna go
or wherever he has an envision wherever
it's gonna go it's gonna probably come
out different but whatever sure yeah I
was really sad when Sam Dez left
rest in peace he's so young then
yeah 15 actually looks older he has a
lot of Drive like he he wants to he
wanted to UM he wanted to stay really do
this but he's pretty young guy to go
[ __ ] move out of his house and it
wasn't then yeah shout out to Sam Dez do
it rest in peace who gets the most
female attention on Sunset Park who
[ __ ] the most I mean um the most
attention that's how I do it probably
Sam right oh and what's the girls all
the girls would follow us that we're
like what the hell are they doing man
yeah every know it Walter won't ever see
you never wait they would show up at
your house yeah no way holy [ __ ] I'm
telling you it's I never seen anything
like this guys like you Sunset Park dude
I think that's the same thing Justin
Bieber gets yeah you're talking about
Sam Dez are you guys in general Sam does
know that's particularly its I seen it
in the comments they're like everybody's
just losing their damn mind over the Sam
Dez that's what happens well literally
they lose their goddamn minds yeah
something in their preview best and
brain they get brain shocked by spiced
cuteness yeah that's what it is so I
know there's two modes in Sunset Park is
that an issue you guys need a battle for
the for the real mo title of the real mo
I know it's not an issue you always be
the real no to me you'll your mode
number one at least he could be mo
number two in my heart anyway I love you
for that
yeah sure tag um I guess my last
question before the end is like where do
you where do you see your guy yourselves
what's next for you guys yeah where do
you see yourself in five years from now
or is there a next thing you're working
on it is this big thing something you
said you don't want to talk about
yeah you don't have to talk about some
you know but what do you see yourself in
five years five years on YouTube man
yeah yeah oh yeah
next five years YouTube's a baby do you
see any problematic how they're cracking
down on like inappropriate content you
said as a challenge for you guys
absolutely not we don't see that as a
challenge because um you have to get
better don't don't don't wish it was
easier you know what I'm saying you just
have to get better that's great that's a
[ __ ] beautiful you have to get
philosophy better that's inspirational
dude and then finally this is kind of
like a tradition here at the podcast we
always ask classic it's just completely
left field do you guys have any ghost
stories ghost stories yeah you like like
behind the camera you guys ever seen
ghosts spirits [ __ ] like that you buried
UFOs weird spooky unexplainable there's
a video on YouTube where you hear stuff
from the sky I've seen that that like a
horn or something yeah that's we touch
it is that real I have I've heard
conflicting things about those that's
weird that's it it is really freaky can
you can you find that in model and
whisper it's like it's really bizarre
it's like a it sounds like the and like
some sci-fi like a [ __ ] horn in the
sky blasting like what was that hey
that's not it dance god damn it
yeah did you find it I'm gonna try to
pull it up it's it's kind of it's hard
to explain man it's just straight there
but okay there is some explanations but
you hear it's hard to accept that it's
just like some atmospheric it sounds
like a and it happens in different
countries too right yeah I want to play
that for you guys but until then we have
some callers you guys mind taking some
some questions from from the audience
all night we don't mind
okay let me pull up some colors and see
what we got here oh we have it hang on
what do we got they talk live or insist
on message now we have a lot what can
take callers live that's I mean I'm here
it is I know you guys see that's that's
exactly yeah it's been only four
innovating yeah we support what you're
doing thank you
all right get on with it this is can't
be what you linked me is it end of times
anyway I see a lot of people saying that
it's fake fake use Internet Explorer
there no it just clicks it and it comes
up man I'm sorry to embarrass myself
like that yeah you're right though
people are saying it's fake yeah well
I'm an idiot then I need to look more
into it I don't know that's muted it's
more like this sound comes out of what
am I missing down other they got a lot
of likes yeah you hear that [ __ ] yeah
something a straight sacrifice movements
I'm gonna try to look more to this cuz
it's almost too bizarre to be real
[Music]
that can't be real way everything but
you could hear it in different countries
yeah no wait well if somebody just edit
it all right yeah maybe I like my
friends across that's what I'm saying
and make it sound realistic yeah anyway
I did anyone in real life hear this
though that witness that is just a video
I think it's probably a collaborative
goof yeah cuz you would see more you
would see more of these anyway
elaborating on that well does Ethan they
want you to say that I'm eatin bread me
and you say yeah best my vision of
naseeban
like the way I said anything that's
what's up guys I'm all Bradberry I'm
Ethan Bradberry I love it you know you
know post alone and yeah I don't know if
you guys heard when he starts all of his
shows by playing ax this is Ethan of you
know I really swear to God
yeah yes yeah every one of his shows who
starts with a dizzy thing you can find
classes where shoutout to post Malone
number one oh wait
he broke party B was dude he broke the
record for most streams in 24 hours on
Apple music sounds good news really good
he's killing it check it out was playing
your voice I respect those respect
respect guys I gotta say was on it was a
joy and a privilege having you here
thank you fan I was pret very very
pleasantly surprised to see how [ __ ]
cool and nice and awesome down to earth
Mike Weisman you guys are going on yeah
I mean oh should we take those and
should we I already said like goodbye
it's all heartfelt and [ __ ] now you want
me to say goodbye again I only see one
person and I don't know okay alright
I'll take one god damn it
alright we'll take one yeah hello oh I'm
not in the room [ __ ]
right hello low neck you got a question
for the Bradbury's all right
maybe this speaker is well as I said
thanks for uh thanks for thanks for that
they gave the callin appreciate that
what's his name : ik long long neck low
Nick thanks for the question buddy
thanks Jonah what was the question
he didn't he never said I think shout on
hello Nick the [ __ ] anyway all right
cool
guys it's been awesome hope you have a
great time in LA come back again yeah
definitely will friends of the show man
thank you everyone alright guys thanks
for watching appreciate you guys next
Tuesday make sure is tuned in we've got
Chi Lopez come then oh yeah
that's a man right there he's in New
York right I'll probably pick Jinyan and
it's funny he lives in LA so anyway
thanks for watching guys
preciate you and we'll see you next time
[Music]